[Music]
foreign
get a kiss from both of his little girls
huh oh no
no Daddy doesn't even get to touch mommy
for a very very very long time
Daddy's really sorry about what he said
near the room he didn't mean any of it
Daddy shouldn't waste his time it only
took two years after an eyebrow raising
entrance in The Wolf of Wall Street for
Margot Robbie to become a big enough
known entity to cameo in movies as
herself like she did in 2015's The Big
Short and by 2018 she was an
oscar-nominated actress thanks to I
Tonya Robbie was nominated for best
supporting actress for bombshell while
her portrayal as Sharon Tate was one of
the sentimental cruxes of Once Upon a
Time in Hollywood which was up for Best
Picture in between all of this Robbie
also became one of the shining stars of
the DC extended universe as Harley Quinn
stealing the show in Suicide Squad with
an upgrade to lead status in Birds of
Prey and she was again one of the best
parts of the suicide squad don't kill me
all right no no seriously am I just
gonna be something something we can
figure out hey
where were you lost something right
you lost something I heard you say a
diamond
yeah
so you are in for a treat because we are
counting down the best Margot Robbie
movies all ranked by Tomato Meter
[Music]
number 10 Whiskey Tango Foxtrot
in 2002 cable news producer Kim Barker
decides to shake up her routine by
taking a daring new assignment in Kabul
Afghanistan dislodged from her
comfortable American lifestyle Barker
finds herself in the middle of an out of
control war zone luckily she meets Tanya
Vanderpool a fellow journalist who takes
the Shell Shocked reporter under her
Wing amid the militants Warlords and
nighttime partying Barker discovers
zikita becoming a successful
correspondent starring Tina Fey Margot
Robbie Martin Freeman and directed by
Glenn ficara and John requa critics say
while Whiskey Tango Foxtrot is far from
Fubar Tina Fey and Martin Freeman are
just barely enough to overcome the
picture's glib predictability and
limited world view did you go to the
tribals because you were in a contract
negotiation dude I'm not stealing your
job okay Tony this is not about my
job
we have to make good calls right and now
Andy Lawson I and John Weed is dead
Christ man boy make mistakes no
tell me you didn't go to the tribals
because of a contract
you would have done exactly what I did
if job we had gone to no no I'm not you
do you remember your first Ember
you interviewed a young Marine what
Coughlin yes what now after they add
your story
where you used his sound bite about not
loading his rifle
they sent him to helmond
and he got his legs blown off
so I hear
[Music]
are you in cardboard
number nine bombshell
the provocative real story of three whip
smart ambitious strong women who
anchored one of America's most powerful
news networks becoming headlines
themselves when they risked everything
to stand up to the man who made them
famous starring Charlize Theron Nicole
Kidman Margot Robbie and directed by Jay
roach critics say bombshell benefits
from a terrific cast and a worthy
subject but its impact is muffled by a
frustrating inability to go deeper than
the sensationalistic surface just kept
talking and kept saying
good girl
that's a good girl be a good soldier
earn your place
he didn't even didn't even unbuckle
[Applause]
head
no I feel like you didn't do anything
wrong
number eight about time
when Tim lake is 21 his father tells him
a secret the men in their family can
travel through time although he can't
change history Tim resolves to improve
his life by getting a girlfriend he
meets Mary falls in love and finally
wins her heart via time travel and a
little cunning however as his unusual
life progresses Tim finds that his
special ability can't Shield him and
those he loves from the problems of
ordinary life starring Domino Gleason
Rachel McAdams Bill Nye Margot Robbie
and directed by Richard Curtis critics
say beautifully filmed and unabashedly
sincere about time finds director
Richard Curtis at his most sentimental
okay the last night was a bad idea very
bad idea it feels like an episode
slightly insulting afterthought
last night was
good
it's got it
[Music]
Tim Charlotte hi
hi
I know you've probably suspected this
but over the last month I've fallen
completely in love with you
now obviously this this was going to
happen because because you're a goddess
with with that faith that hair
but even if you didn't have a nice face
and even if you had absolutely no hair
because of some bizarre medical reason
I'd still adore you
and I
I just wondered whether by any chance
you might share my feelings
wow
tell me what
why don't we see how the summer goes and
then you ask me again on my last night
your last night
number seven sweet francaise her husband
away at War a lonely French woman begins
a tentative romance with a refined
German Soldier who has taken up
residence in her mother-in-law's house
starring Michelle Williams Matthias
schoenerts Kristen Scott Thomas Margot
Robbie and directed by Saul din critics
say sweet francaise takes an understated
approach to its period romance which
along with strong performances from a
talented cast Haze absorbing dividends
the hair
madame
you're looking for Library
[Music]
foreign
number six Z for Zachariah
following a disaster that wipes out most
of civilization a scientist and a minor
compete for the love of a woman who may
be the last female on earth starring
chuatel edgio 4 Margot Robbie Chris Pine
and directed by Craig zobel critics say
Z for Zechariah Rings compelling drama
out of its simplistic premise albeit at
a pace that made tests the patients of
less contemplative viewers
quick
okay
it's just me you just need to get out of
the water please please it's just water
comes from outside the valley
you just need to get out of the water
please
[Music]
foreign
number five birds of prey
it's open season on Harley Quinn when
her explosive breakup with the joker
puts a big fat Target on her back
unprotected and On The Run Quinn faces
the wrath of narcissistic Crime Boss
black mask his right hand man Victor and
every other Thug in the city but things
soon even out for Harley when she
becomes unexpected allies with three
deadly women Huntress Black Canary and
Renee Montoya starring Margot Robbie
Rosie Perez Mary Elizabeth Winstead and
directed by Kathy Yan critics say with a
fresh perspective some new friends and
loads of fast-paced action Birds of Prey
captures the colorfully anarchic spirit
of Margot Robbie's Harley Quinn
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
Number Four The Wolf of Wall Street in
1987 Jordan Belfort takes an entry-level
job at a Wall Street brokerage firm now
by the early 1990s while still in his
20s Belford found his own firm at
Stratton Oakmont together with his
trusted lieutenant and a merry band of
Brokers Belfort makes a huge Fortune by
defrauding wealthy investors out of
millions however while Bill Fort and his
cronies partake in a hedonistic Brew of
sex drugs and thrills the SEC and the
FBI close in on his Empire of excess
starring Leonardo DiCaprio Jonah Hill
Margot Robbie and directed by Martin
Scorsese critics say funny
self-referential and irreverent to a
fault The Wolf of Wall Street finds
Martin Scorsese and Leonardo DiCaprio at
their most infectiously dynamic you're a
father now Jordan yeah you're a father
now I know and you're still acting
baby you know yo you got real anger
issues you got someone who flew in here
at three in the morning on that stupid
helicopter and woke up Skyla that was
yours
doesn't matter to you that I just had
that driving range started with Bermuda
grass oh Jordan
grass no you didn't research the whole
thing and deal with the Golf
Course oh my God you had to deal with
the golf course people too what a Greek
tragedy honey oh my God you probably had
to pay them in cash with your hands what
a burden and actually do some
work besides swiping my credit
card all day huh cause I can't keep
track of your professions honey because
last month you were a wine connoisseur
now you're an aspiring landscape
architect let me get that right no
dare throw that water at
me no you dare
number three Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood
actor Rick Dalton gained Fame and
Fortune by starring in a 1950s
television Western but is now struggling
to find meaningful work in a Hollywood
that he doesn't recognize anymore he
spends most of his time drinking and
paling around with Cliff Booth his
easy-going best friend and long time
stunt double Rick also happens to live
next door to Roman Polanski and Sharon
Tate the filmmaker and budding actress
whose Futures will forever be altered by
members of the Manson family starring
Leonardo DiCaprio Brad Pitt Margot
Robbie and directed by Quentin Tarantino
critics say thrillingly unrestrained yet
solidly crafted Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood temper's Tarantino's
provocative impulses with the clarity of
a mature filmmaker's vision
hey Reuben come out here
this is the girl from Valley of the
Dolls
Patty Duke no the other one
the girl from Peyton plays no the other
one the one who ends up doing dirty
movies
she's in this movie oh Sharon Tate wow
welcome to the Bruin mistake thank you
for coming to our theater would you like
to come in and see the show could I by
all means
thank you
hey can I get a picture oh sure
you know why don't you stand over by the
poster so people will know who you are
okay
would you like some refreshments oh I'm
fine thank you enjoy the show
number two the Suicide Squad Welcome to
Hell AKA Bell Reeve the prison with the
highest mortality rate in the U.S of a
we're the worst super villains are kept
and where they will do anything to get
out even join the super secret super
Shady task force x today's Do or Die
assignment assemble a collection of cons
including Bloodsport Peacemaker Captain
Boomerang rat catcher 2 Savant king
shark blackguard Javelin and everyone's
favorite psycho Harley Quinn then arm
them heavily and drop them literally on
the remote enemy infused island of Cordo
Maltese trekking through a jungle
teeming with militant adversaries and
gorilla forces at every turn the squad
is on a search and destroy mission with
only Colonel Rick flag on the ground to
make them behave and Amanda Waller's
government techies in their ears
tracking their every movement if
anyone's laying down beds the smart
money is against them all of them
starring Margot Robbie Idris Elba John
Cena and directed by James Gunn critics
say in Ivan by writer director James
Gunn singularly skewed Vision The
Suicide Squad marks a funny fast-paced
rebound that plays to the source
materials violent anarchic strengths
what does TGK stand for what your name
is TGK correct yeah and it stands for
what
stands for me that's what a name is your
name is letters all knives are letters
did
I love your accent American women all
love accents do
because we don't got none
yo is this a dog what is this thing a
dog
a dog yes what what kind of dog do you
think it is mate I don't know I'm not
familiar with all the breeds I'm gonna
go with Afghan Hound she's witnessing
Afghan and a bloody thumbs oh my God is
it a werewolf I wanted to meet a
werewolf forever yeah
he's not a werewolf okay he's a weasel
he's harmless I think he's not harmless
he's killed 27 children but you know we
got him to I think he's agreed to do
this whatever the case does everyone get
in a position to drop
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
Mary Queen of Scots
[Music]
France at 16 and Widow to 18. Mary
Stewart defies pressure to remarry
instead she returns to her native
Scotland to reclaim her rightful throne
but Scotland and England fall under the
rule the compelling Elizabeth the first
each young Queen beholds her sister in
fear and Fascination rivals in power and
in love and female Regents in a
masculine world the two must decide how
to play the game of marriage versus
Independence starring sercia Ronan
Margot Robbie Jack Loden and directed by
Josie Rourke critics say Mary Queen of
Scots delivers uneven period political
Thrills while offering a solid showcase
for the talents of its well-matched
leads we are rewarding her Disobedience
what disobedience
she is not our subject and yet you would
make us hers
what have you produced in all your
troubles between our kingdoms
Discord
War
death
and now you have the boldness to doubt
my judgment
you had better question yours
I regret that you perceive me as a
failure
we serve you fully
with all our hearts any one of us would
gladly die for you but Mary is our Foe
and a Catholic she is only your queen if
I should not produce an air and will you
madam
for you have given us little hope so far
despite your every effort she has
prevailed
it's proven herself in fact far more
capable than my own privy Council
should I die before my time we could do
worse than to place her on the third
living goodbye Christopher Robin
after leaving London for the English
Countryside writer A.A Milne starts to
spin fanciful Yarns about his son's
growing collection of stuffed animals
these stories form the basis for Winnie
the Pooh and the house at Pooh Corner
published respectively in 1926 and 1928.
Milne and his family soon become swept
up in the instant success of the books
while the enchanting Tales bring hope
and comfort to the rest of post-war
England starring Domino Gleason Margot
Robbie Kelly McDonald and directed by
Simon Curtis critics say goodbye
Christopher Robin struggles to balance
wartime tension and childlike Wonder but
offers valuable insight into the
darkness shadowing the creation of a
classic children's Tale
how lovely to see you welcome to your
study look here's a desk do you remember
desks what are you talking about you
said you were bringing us here to write
something
so write something
you're a writer who doesn't write I'm
thinking but let's hear your great
thoughts I'm thinking about where we go
next London no not us England where does
England go next
the country is wounded death
it's lost man yes but it's lost more
than that
we need a sense of purpose don't you see
that
the nations of the world they got
together and banned slavery well what if
we did the same with War what if we all
all nations got together and decided
that when there was a conflict when
there was a dispute war was no way to
settle that war would go the way of the
slave trade
yes that proves my point exactly
no
you weren't making a point
my point is I have to go to London to
look at Wiley's new wallpaper collection
what
right fine yes it is fine because do you
know what writing a book against war is
like no tell me it's like writing a book
against Wednesdays Wednesdays blue are a
fact of life and if you don't like them
you could stay in bed but you can't stop
them because Wednesdays are coming and
if today isn't actually a Wednesday it
soon will be
bye
and finally number one I Tonya in 1991
talented figure skater Tanya Harding
becomes the first American woman to
complete a triple Axel during a
competition in 1994 her world comes
crashing down when her ex-husband
conspires to injure Nancy Kerrigan a
fellow Olympic hopeful in a poorly
conceived attack that forces a young
woman to withdraw from the national
championship Harding's Life and Legacy
instantly become tarnished as she's
forever associated with one of the most
infamous scandals in sports and history
starring Margot Robbie Sebastian Stan
Allison Janney and directed by Craig
Gillespie critics say led by strong work
from Margot Robbie and Allison Janney
itanya finds the humor in its real life
story without losing sight of its more
tragic and emotionally resonant elements
all I did was
the hindering of prosecution
what you're never
gonna let me skate again
I can't ever I mean
I'd rather do the jail time please the
they only got 18 months
they got 18 months I'll do that
you can't
your honor
I don't have an education
all I know is skating that's all I know
and I I am no one if I can't no I can't
I'm I'm not
I mean I'm not some monster I'm just
I'm just trying to I'm trying to do the
best with what I know how to do and
you're giving me it's like you're giving
me a life sentence if you do that you
can't do that Miss Harding that's enough
you can't please because
you send me to jail and then I can still
skate
the jail and then I'm giving you my
decision
[Music]
well my friends that about does it for
us be sure to stay tuned to the Rotten
Tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content you love until
next time I am your host Naz Perez and
we'll see you back here for more top
tens on the Rotten Tomatoes countdown
[Music]
foreign